[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hello hello everybody you what is us
how's it going at Persia here and we are
here with GameSpot live and today's
stream is also powered by truth which is
awesome and also why we're doing a
really cool theme today all of our
challenges today are gonna be Iran I'm
gonna be boosting and other things like
that because it's really important now
than ever to stay feeling top-notch and
you know a thing can actually weaken
your immune system and that's really not
what we want we want to be able to take
care of ourselves and to be honest if I
can put you guys even quit so let's get
to it because if you guys tuned in last
week then you know we've had a bunch of
cool stuff planned we had all the races
and all the shenanigans going down which
was awesome and then at the end of the
last dream we got these five contestants
who were tuning in to be a part of this
stream so I know I saw some of you guys
in the chat already that you know you
want to join in but all the slots filled
up from viewers who tuned in last week
so now we are here we've got oh I don't
know if you saw also on my board but
these are our contestants who are tuning
in because if one of our players wins a
real challenge they will get IRL merch
from truth as well so yeah and what is
up chat Lia berry drop-dead gorgeous he
can't go commie white evil a JD or a
gamer what is good squishy
I see branding the new trot he's also in
here as a contestant today yeah we've
got Brandon and Steph and fast and and
Aaron they are gonna be competing today
up first lot of stuff actually so I'm
gonna give you guys a little rundown of
what our games are gonna be like today
just like I did last time so that you at
least know what to expect we're gonna
take a look at the mount but the upper
side is gonna look blank because it's
all fences and trees so it's not gonna
show up on the map but there is stuff up
there at the top we're gonna have our
rise and shine race to kick it off
because you know getting a good
Bres getting proper sleep and all that
is very important for boosting your
immune system plus generally I just like
sleeping a lot as well so two great ones
done with that so we're gonna have our
rise and shine race which is a little
bit different than last time um maybe
not as complex but a little bit more
involved a little bit more activities so
we'll go over that then we're gonna have
a couple of rounds are gonna have a race
to three wins in some bug and fish
catching you know get that exercise
going exercise is important so that is
the theme we're trying to channel there
try to run around you know get an arm
workout going fishing and then you know
if it was like a week in the future from
now then we would be able to dive into
the water I don't know if you guys saw
that update those announcements morning
but let's go I'm excited to go swimming
really really awesome and something to
the cardew's so and guys down the child
we got one of these in the future
definitely just stay tuned to the
GameSpot channel because you know you
can be one of these contestants who are
in the game right now in the future so
yeah I've been asking about so we are
going to do our tree transport challenge
where it's gonna be a race to see who
can eat ten fruit and move ten trees
from one designation to another the
fastest and then we're gonna have the
Fashion Show which I'm very excited
about because I worked really hard on
the runway I tried a million different
things I thought was gonna channel the
beach vibe but I finally settled on
something really fun and I can't wait
each contestant has inked outfits we
have four themes that we've selected and
then four themes that's player's choice
so a lot of variety I can't wait to see
what everyone came up with I will go
over the beams once we get so the
fashion show it's gonna be really fun
and yeah hello
I'm welcome and yes update looks super
cute you guys I am excited after all of
this all of that is said and done we're
gonna go through the boosted Beltre race
because it's a crazy maze that I feel
and you guys are gonna have to eat fruit
and dig up trees and move them just to
get through the race on the other side
I've got I've got some goodies I've got
some gold nuggets a lot of them else but
I've got a lot of music see it if you
saw on Twitter the screenshots I posted
you already know tons of bells
obviously not miles tickets obviously
all the goods so let's just go ahead and
get right into it because a lot of our
players are here and all right so let's
get down to the very first race I'm
gonna be typing to them some brief
instructions lines talking to you guys
so let's [ __ ] multitasking kicks off
alright dig ok first Rick Klemme start
up various race exclamation point
yeah
take a bed don't leave them in fact
that's a good first introduction dig up
flowers and match color and match dots
Oh dots de ot there we go and match that
[Music]
I will activate timer I gotta keep these
ashore and I'll short and sweet all
right
pick your bed you guys okay so the way I
set this up is a similar to last time
but different because I've incorporated
them matching flowers to the colors
which they'll be able to dig up the
second to get out of it but they have to
get the shovel first because I've had
everyone start with no tools I've
allowed them to bring a one that has
their outfit
[Music]
so they will have to run through you
know any wakeup you gotta hit the
bathroom then they will jump over the
little pond a pond in your house you
know Bujji
and then you will pick up the shovel and
then you gotta kind of retrace your
steps back because you also have to get
this orange which will help you out of
the race later through the tree then you
got to sit down in the chair first one
to their chair when so let's see who the
goodies in there some McMullen stickers
and other things so get ready alright it
is time it is time I'm setting the timer
off this shouldn't take them more than
five minutes but let's start it oh I'm
excited first game of the day
let's see they've begun they've started
alright they're already making it
through ooh quick lightning speed again
manic mouth ticket but eye on the prize
up here going straight for the shovel
they're assessing the situation let's
see how our other contestants are doing
down here at the bottom I swear we can
see a little bit of what everyone is
doing
okay okay going straight for the
business like this I'm told we did it
die get those in empty and then c83
except for here Oh oops this is a part
of the race everyone needs to become my
best friend
obviously oops I was supposed to do this
beforehand okay that's three out of five
let's get our other players in here
oxygen best friends best friends wait
our kid all right I'm gonna tell them
since three quints
all right so it looks like we're making
their way through oh you should try and
dig up the tree but you have to go fine
[Music]
that adds to their what they have to do
they might not finish this in five
minutes actually okay I see them picking
up the flowers over that
[Music]
hey Barry if we do have fun next week I
will definitely post on Twitter about it
I'm not sure for gonna actually but we
saw that there's some new updates so we
might be able to do something really I
will be vocal about it online if we do
win another one of these so see - I'm
waiting to see everyone's progress going
ok Pisa
you see is that the oranges er but I
think he's gonna leave it and wait until
he puts some of these flowers down and
also in here is not see that's a part of
the puzzle
I do have extra fruit just in case
people accident lamps get rid of their
[Music]
Wow
I have to shred in this
all right flowers orange dawn I spelled
that room and wait slow white dots
abbreviations yeah be careful for a
toilet oh he found something I need some
bells
yeah so you know and what's one person
still gets it then oh don't they see you
later I'm all for two now I also put oh
wait wait wait
yeah there we go
I had put one your pockets is our your
pockets full you were supposed to empty
them a violent the trash can by the door
all these games require maximum pocket
space you know it's okay you ran out of
time
but yeah how are you how's chat while
our smaller contestants are busy at work
going with the color matching challenge
know this I feel like a good
representation of what it's like to wake
up in the morning right wake up
you have so much to do today and in all
starts with organizing your day first
thing so I tried to channel organizing
your day into organizing the flowers to
color coordinate with the dots oh I
actually was not looking to see who made
it first but I'm gonna say your pop
winner is the first winner because it's
only here and they were the first to get
a pony and stethoscope - fruit again you
know like if digestion is always oh it's
always days of being extras
alright so let's get let's go ahead and
watch this board right here where I put
it
[ __ ] mark for tests and a check mark for
Aaron hangout the rise and shine raves
mini puzzle ask thing you know - yeah
it's not too bad but definitely just
takes a little bit of order of
operations winches fiber exits it's all
good for the intestines chairs are I
seriously doubt in this game good job
you guys
very nice you left some scientists if so
we find because the games were already
done alright let's see is everyone
sitting in their chair yeah
[Music]
I mean yeah he might just run alright
it's fine come on through so it's fine
yeah let's let's get to the next game
nice try though friend Azusa all right
all right very nice very nice looks like
our contestants are ready up next so
continuing our theme here you guys
because if you're just tuning in right
now today's stream is powered by truth
this is actually the second animal
crossing train that we've had where
we've had these fun games so yeah thank
you guys for tuning in and we were
continuing our games the next one is bug
and fish catchy first do three rounds
wins which I'm going to have to count
three rounds wins three minutes
the first should we do one minute I'll
do various times how about that keep
them on their toes all right
staying in the area
[Music]
[Music]
alright let me drop
because I don't another bring anything
so I need to make sure that they have
stuff to fish and even though Brandon
did not listen to my rules by the way
Brandon shame on you just kidding
I was gonna give you a fishing rod
anyways so slowly fine I'm also gonna
drop you guys uh net if you want to
catch some bug there's a lot of digging
involved today because we get our
exercise guys stay nice and strong I
think everyone all right boom right
she'll begin I have way too much by
doing this I like being like the game
master alright
I'm sitting yeah we're sitting all right
let me get my butt all the way and let's
get the first round goin the first one
300 and there is no 1 minute okay first
round three minutes let's go we might
just do that you may well be for time
sake its first two three so all of the
missions I did allow them to bring fish
bait if they want it but there's three
rounds the whip so there's really only
so much fish bait they could've probably
brought
I'm not worried about how am i typing so
fast on switch I actually have my
keyboard hooked up to my dog because
there's no way I can type that fast so
whoa they're having at it
[Music]
[Music]
I did not so crappy on the I still don't
but I always try to get up and like walk
around do some stretches a little bit
more if you played animal ground thing
they're all you're doing yoga and stuff
and every time I see them doing yoga I
need to go way and what is up welcome
back how you do it
we are chillin right now we are getting
our exercise and we're fishing everyone
right now is competing for some IRL
truth marriage and a bunch of really
nice getting suit so while everyone's
running around and fishing I'm just
gonna you know they might not notice
this here for a while see how they're
doing
ooh some medicine someone else on that
you know it's Brandon his pockets are
full he's just littering all through the
island it's fine I was something that
you know maybe putting some flowers and
something here to help warm books but
that's why I put lots of water areas to
help people fish they can use the ocean
area also no one's picked up the gold
the nugget yeah
haha you know people who brought fish
bait they might get some early rounds
now but the next few rounds might not be
so easy because they don't have fish
meat souls
oh I see rounds go oh it's in seconds
left let's see I'll be able to go into
the phone shop oh he's not giving oh and
that is it Hathi oh my goodness so weird
ah we have ADD and calculate everything
up together so let's look at the
scoreboard here you guys Erin with two
Stephanie was seven our kid with three
in total Brandon with three in Seoul and
testing with eight because she got four
and four fish so she is gonna miss round
out we're putting a dot here for tests
on the board she accumulates three dots
well she wanted she already won a
challenge show then the second place
winner so it's all it's all happening
and it's all coming together
no fish bring was Otto lost Oh still
if you've got this all right round
numbers you'll want to do you know we
have some downtime in between sets you
know when you work out you have to you
know do your sets and then you gotta
take it a little bit catch your breath
and then oh my goodness I'm just gonna
spin that's big shadow that's very rare
fish I'm just stand here and wait and
see you and there's there's a butterfly
here too there's a butterfly
[Music]
oh my goodness glue and animal cross
I've actually never seen my eyes to
check that up for sure oh snap this has
spotted the giant shadow in the water
hopefully it's not like
trash or something though of you hurtin
it even though I feast on testicles
no I don't think it counts trash
actually I just want to see what this
dish is someone catch it
oh that's a good one oh snap I just
don't see what it is let's go I don't
know the name of it but I've seen that
before
noise noise alright let's see how
everyone else is
oh I haven't dropped a gold nugget
recently let me do that we're halfway
through the round I think at least
halfway through the round desert a
surprise a surprise let's go see you and
I went up to over dere I'm so curious to
see what everyone is that so far
[Music]
also you guys might notice that the date
is in the past that's because this
island is in the southern hemisphere and
it was snowing today
and I want to celebrate the fun in the
Sun so I had to adjust the day so we
could get some nice sunny by it
[Music]
how's it going happy Thursday we are in
the middle of round two of some good old
exercise we are bug and fish catching
right now everyone's up running everyone
is constantly running I know they're
getting their exercises and yeah first
three rounds wins the first round went
to test we still have a lot after this
ooh we have the tree transport challenge
we have the fashion show and we have the
tree maze which ends up Oh
all right so have Erin with seven
stephanie week to me with nada we got
our kid with five Brandon with you and
testy with quiet so Erin time dollar you
know Vice lamps like to do so top no we
are time oh so what
[Music]
alright are we ready alright so back at
it like the tunes I sprout like a radio
everything I did leave this area of if
you guys tune in to our first stream
this is where we've had
scavenger hunt the spa doctor but you
may notice now is where our fashion show
is going to be helped I was originally
going to have it on the beach but I've
recreated a very beautiful beach runway
inside it's gonna give us some awesome
angles that we don't miss any of the
beautiful outfits or accessorize with us
today I think let me just check to make
sure someone's fat gold nugget I don't
want them to be too close to my tropics
No
oh so now because I've lose a dragonfly
we're also in the time where the
dragonflies is a really fast
I hope they release the fish after it
because their pockets might get bill
I'm gonna drop another go home huh get
over here okay
Oh getting those lunges in like days
don't skip leg day you got the very
impressed day honestly I feel like when
I was going to the gym like they was
actually my favorite hot add AB we're
running out of space already I see all
those resources and stuff scattered
about yeah big fella fishtail but
they're gonna get anywhere near the
amount they could did I see in
and also you guys if you didn't know
I've created some truth designs that are
in the game that you can actually
download here's the Creator throw it
down at the bottom left of the screen
and the relax T is actually a real piece
of merchandise that the contestants are
going to be winning today if they win a
challenge so do you want to download any
one of the designs that you're gonna be
seeing today just go ahead check out
that creator code and it sounds like the
round just finished let's go ahead and
see what the score is for round number
three Oh someone got their first E or I
feel nice alright so stephanie was to
Erin with four arcade with three Brandon
with volleys and testy with four so
Brandon has now swooped in and gotten a
point Oh amazing it's closed
so
[Music]
[Music]
all right round five 100 wrong I'm gonna
cop it around okay so this is Round four
everyone's ending their pockets like it
and they're releasing a little bit all
right here we go all right so it's worth
the whole thing because Brandon and we
press have one point and Erin so that's
an errand have already won so if by some
miracle they both win then either bring
up Brandon
I urge for this challenge so we will see
it's actually going to look closer
tonight because I know not everybody had
frogfish pit stop so oh my goodness
doing gymnastics and Doris sounds
dangerous
who you be terrible it's animal crossing
only Fernando
[Music]
oh yeah whoo there's dragonfly here whoa
then she got in the first one graceful
graceful that was the arm strength right
there and the power to swing the net
with such accuracy oh she's been spat
over here whoo they're finding the gold
I must have drop I must drop more
push-ups themselves oh no I didn't do
that I wanted to drop it and I'll run
way over here
at least one time bring a frown drop
pity but everyone getting their exercise
[Music]
so I would assume at about now our
players and our contestants are running
out of faith I love these reactions in
this game especially when you're with
your friends and you're like sending a
team up to each other
Oh Sakura and the fat is also opening up
there I'll in anybody who wants the
business because I know some of you
wanted to join in on today's best video
but all of the slots got filled from the
viewers if you tuned in from last
streams so yeah if you guys want to hang
out while you're tuning in go hang out
all right let's check out the score mood
this looks really close to so Erin with
five Stephanie with four turtle with
four Brandon with one and test seed with
five so Aaron and Tessie tied so they're
both going to give get a point so Aaron
and test tied
so hello a time both get a point
yeah so pest and Aaron to please
Oh plus no I'm it spit equal no wait
what if what am I doing here equal there
we go you two boys and has one point s
or Aaron win the they can pick someone
to give their price yes price already
won
all right so now I'm gonna let them and
have a little bit more liberty over
where their windows and I feel like
that's that's more fair okay round five
which could potentially be the last
round because Aaron and tests are bug
and fish touching faster let's get the
next round go all right
it begins and they're setting all the
fishies free these issues sorry to catch
you in the first place we just needed
some exercise and if you guys are just
tuning in with us now then you should
know that today's stream is powered by
truth this is second stream awareness
very important explain your help
immunity be seen combating stress so if
you tuned in last time we saw all of our
mini games from combating stress I think
the healthy contest shuts and now this
time is all about staying strong
boosting your immunity
sure that we're seeing in joining us
because we're having a lot of fun we are
on round five of our bug and
fish-catching
going on here and this is only the
second game that we played today so far
so we had a rise and shine rate we now
have our buck and fish-catching
challenge and this will have three more
really fun things to go we could very
well reach our winner of this round I've
been running around dropping little
frozen here and there first for everyone
so while they're running around catching
stuff they also Chinese things on the
floor and then a Chris later the grand
prize for our final challenge a lot of
goals a lot of old a lot of in empties a
lot of those hopefully people have Plex
piece last stream I had so many prizes
that literally everyone's pockets are
full I had a little bit left over I
might have been overboard but I had a
lot of fun and that's
why I'm like so stoked to make these
little obstacle Christian stuff and I
want everybody to have some cool stuff
and get some money and go take it to
their IRA and build the greatest Islands
we've ever seen some pretty cool I'm so
far who there's a finishing over here in
the plot on the sand axis Oh someone's
going for it oh I don't want to run next
to it because I don't want it to go away
so close no don't run oh my there's
three people are buying for this fish oh
ha oh that's so messed up
[Music]
imagine being a yellow card right there
but that was pretty cool they were all
not going for it all right one second
who's got it let's see let's check the
scoreboard shall we alright Erin with
six Stephanie with five 7,000 second
like everything on time
seventy-one five arcade with to see with
four and Brandon with one so that means
Erin
[Music]
I love that reaction alright so we're
letting Aaron pick a winner because he
actually is on the first challenge um so
he's eligible for an another piece of
mesh peewee gets a prick so we're
letting him take his win and pick to be
once again honestly I feel like step was
one underneath firstly every single time
I checked
[Music]
oh do my hot route
okay have a beer beer I move over in the
room I relax
yes
[Music]
okay I'm gonna fit two minute break to
dumb fish okay so I'm gonna give
everyone two minutes to dump their fish
and their bugs I have to run over here
and buy some more fruit my name on this
island is actually there's been a
million times where I felt like I'm
about to catch cold or something I'm
like nope I need to take some vitamin C
always all right get some fruits I have
ten are you guys enjoying the games so
far thanks for taking this really great
with us well our contestants and so
originally I was gonna have them eat the
oranges as a part of the race but I feel
like that would take a lot of time so
I'm gonna have them eat it ahead of time
and then we're gonna time them and see
how fast they can move ten trees and I
have it all set up here so let me see I
have four Eddie I'm just gonna get ten
more images and I think our contestant
should be ready and done dumping they're
efficient bugs so let's grab these two I
see uh Sakura has also post our
Herodotus code in the chat for those of
you watching who wants you hang out
maybe you guys can have your own little
watch party on her Island
on their Island apologies so you guys
can all hang out on the island and
watches it seems like all right I have
all the oranges now I think they're
ready too because now they are typing to
us
[Music]
I will definitely answer their question
once I am done passing
all right so let's see what they asked
me try me this tree in my pocket planted
that tree long time ago to do that to
move okay let's see okay
oh I spelled that so wrong in this
challenge
in this challenge everyone
[Music]
[Music]
wait uninterrupted time everyone's
trenching guide to eat your fruits
inside you very important look how it is
[Music]
[Music]
haha alright well looks like Brandon is
400 okay okay all right here I'm gonna
go first
all right cool
[Applause]
all right so we are going to time him
starting and now all right
[Music]
no no no no not that one I tried to make
it
[Music]
yeah you know you guys gotta cheer for
him
oops wrong when I'm innocent I know he's
your competitor oh snap ooh you know the
trick was planting the trees design he
can actually just stand in front of the
block with his shovel on and go to the
tree and hit plant without having a big
hole but you can that's a secret
cheering so this started at three
minutes so he was at one minute ten
seconds right now he's making his way
Osiris
well thank you so much for tuning in
hopefully you'll tune in with us right
now in the middle place also just live
everything but today stream this stream
right here this Howard make sure doing
all this cool stuff all these fun
challenges and giving away both IRL and
in-game
get that last tree in there and I'm the
113 RA so one minutes and 13 seconds
were left on the clock which means it
was what's 3-1 13 to wait three that's
one minute and one minute and my mental
map is so bad so let me tell them stop
okay all right so 113 113 left on block
so I think that was 1 minute and 47 47
seconds I think that sounds right that
was 1 minute
[Music]
so one minute and 47 seconds on the ice
all right one minute and 47 seconds
all right up twos up next let's keep it
fair loves keep it fair 147 all right
Thank You Josh in the chat I was like
all right I should get rid of this tree
so there's no confusion you know you
gotta make sure the playing field or
even there all right are we ready
[Music]
okay let's do it
that's the timer three
you guys go sit down yeah paucity one
minute in 47 seconds
ooh he's doing a different approach
because our last contestant Aaron he dug
up all the trees in a row and then I ran
over and planted them so let's see
literally me so he's lying one at a time
let's see if this pans out and I see not
the trick
oh he does know the trick that's
definitely gonna cut out at least like
two seconds of planting time per tree
times 10 is like 20 seconds so on
straight
[Music]
I'm just gonna make sure we keep minimal
downtime in between the brown again the
pink in the pain re I need to pay
attention I really need to suck one tree
I might be able to yeah flashy okay 133
132 1 o 31 1 130 all right that means
130 the other way 130 there where so 130
oh forgot the one
there we go all right nice minute in 30
seconds very fast
yeah the gears are first alright people
get to see how you do
[Applause]
but kickers okay I'm gonna break the
other way also all right it looks like
Brandon wants to go next I need to uh
fix this or else it's just gonna drive
me insane
there we go all right nice and orderly
okay ready Brandon oh wait let's stop
that
all those now okay so let me stop that
[Music]
[Music]
his shuttle broke
[Music]
okay
okay okay okay no all right hold up let
me fix this for you sorry guys we are
gonna get through this
I'm not your paper I can live myself
it's not fair for everyone
No okay okay it has to be fair for the
integrity of the island games everyone
gets a fair shot okay all right let's do
it
I think he's ready all right let's go
boom know what you can start that's a
regular schedule of programming you guys
there we go oh he's going the same route
as Aaron and he's gonna get all the
trans up first which is easier for me
because then I can follow him and close
up all the dig site
[Music]
hey Oliver I am good Arnie oh and Jack
Walsh how's it goin thanks for tuning in
alright Brandon is on to the planting
process also
she's approaching his purse a minute Oh
what's happening he's a duck the hole
you got it
what are you play plant the tree round
in one Freddy what is happening we don't
need the cheese all right well Brandon
let's give it up but we still need the
cheese thank you
so secretly I'm still cleaning him he
says he's given up but I'm still gonna
take the score once he's planted all the
shoes need to give up this process you
know it's supposed to reset itself like
the musical chairs we had last time
all right well did try anyways I'm still
low-key keeping score all right so it
looks like two minutes and 25 seconds
[Music]
all right let's end the timer timer stop
[Music]
who's next
[Music]
let's go step alright who she she was
right next to the tree she was like I'm
gonna make sure I am ready make sure
we're all again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she already looks like she is moving
with the swiftness right now let the
swiftness she only has one Cherie lesson
dig up know why can't be raisins oh
she's digging each and this is gonna go
dig each hole and then go back and plant
each stratum an interesting strategy
interesting strategy here I don't know
where Brandon would which worries me
where you have written
[Music]
all right a minute 40 on the clock which
means just 10 seconds
Bobby she she has five seconds all she
does is make it which means turtle is
still in the lead three more trees 107
that means it was 253 me first up weight
153 153 Brit step
ah that's okay it was still great Hey
alright let me run one let me put yeah
all right 30 all right let's go last Ron
she has to be 130 to win this challenge
just starting right in whatever she's
closest to I like that idea
no lag after this you guys it's time for
the fashion show very excited about and
then the tree race and then that's still
a lot of stuff that only sounds like do
things but it's gonna be a lot and I'm
actually so excited for the Fashion Show
is next
and if you guys are just tuning in you
should know that today we are powered by
truth such as why we are definitely
owning all of our skills on some ways to
boost our city and our I mean because
that is very very pretty especially
right now and we you can do that is
staying in shape good exercise eating
your fruits and vegetables you know the
number one thing is to not be thing is
very bad for you system so not much more
I can tell you there's a lot of ways
that you can to boost your immune system
and it all starts with the choice I made
some heavy traces and my time oh snap
she's almost there one more so fast but
yeah like I mentioned earlier you guys I
quit while back and I'm Agnew you can do
it so yeah oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you win
pick him stick someone so many winners
already we gotta spread the bomb
rounding all right now just passed it on
to you see still participated and all
right
fashion show yeah oh yes you do deserve
it you do just for showing up and being
here and being you exactly let's go you
guys all right I am so excited because I
worked really hard on this runway
I wanted to channel oh okay I've made up
upper floor the only one accessible oh
yeah okay so this is a via fashion show
saige I'm going to lie on but when the
show begins the lights are coming down
so
I am so obsessed with this runway this
is our Muscle Beach fashion show and
I've brought the beach inside so we can
get all the angles so you know so I'm
gonna start with getting the nice angles
here yeah oh I can't tie it okay okay
that's fine I will set up the camera
afterwards and you already know I had
this akk house on or for the fashion
show
nice test making sure she has the
perfect seat where is okay I hear
footsteps I was like where is everyone
[Music]
so in this area you know I want everyone
to start here
get your warned out choose your outfit
walk it down to us do a spin then head
back to switch to your next outfit so
that is what I'm gonna let them all know
when it's your turn
change your office here and runway so I
don't have my one but I'll do an example
here so I'm gonna be like yo so I'm
doing examples let me know what we're
looking for so we can get maximum
effects
got it
you see enough right we get maximum
fashion locking out of each office you
first Turtles no weight test first all
right
oh wait wait wait oh hold on one second
one second one second wait wait wait I
got it
I gotta get off the mall yeah oh yeah
she's got the little paws and little
headband I love they got the shell
approach very beachy love it love it
amazing amazing now I gotta get the zoom
in here get the optimal angle next
outfit yeah uh go out here yeah
next outfit let's get the reveal orange
juice oh stop is so cute in case you
guys didn't know we do have some themes
that are fitting in with our immunity
boosting series we had orange the color
or the merch which is what we saw here
we had orange the fruit so that was back
and we have a fitness theme so Jim work
on how we can you jump feeling powerful
don't like superheroes love it and then
we also have a beach theme so Fitness
theme of each team and then for players
choice so that is our themes here every
night love the matching hat and got the
DAO sunglasses cute exclusive merch love
it and now we are run to the for laser
strike I fell team very adorable loss
snuggly finally with this with the coat
I mean don't go outside of that but very
cute oh very nice you Lana you got that
you've got the Oh was it called handmade
crown I love those so much combinations
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the colors
very nice level backpack the color
combinations very good oh okay this is
the originating outfit which was very
cute you know I got that Fuji Mickey
love it oh let me strap what you got
[Music]
I'm oh wait I need to set up the camera
[Music]
let's have Brandon go next oh wait yeah
yeah all right now let me set up the
camera all right okay here we go here we
go here is it ooh the heart of work
right I like it perfect color
combination love in the shoes I love it
look he's ready to go work
let's get the zoom in here the reveal
the big reveal outfit number three
oh yeah the beach vibes Seren full
effects oh I'm enjoying combos you've
got going on so far and thank you for
not putting socks on with those sandwich
yes thank you very nice very nice outfit
number five you can hopefully up to bare
feet that's the kiss logo
all right so don't touch your mean guys
if I got that wrong I'm gonna spin in my
chair a few times yes all right let's
see what's next
oops already did that one
Oh is he about to change his hairstyle
because I did leave a mirror at the end
of the runway just in case people wanted
to change their hairstyle oh oh he
didn't leave that one on but I did see a
black life matters shirt oh snap
got the designer outfits the designer
hoodies still on clean with the sandals
sandals in every color why not he's
really liking outfit number three oh
okay that was some where's the orange
oh very nice surprise
please choice loving the suspenders Mary
here
[Applause]
[Music]
outfit number six okay
channel the horror vibes
oh yeah that's got something worth the
shock babe I love the use of the custom
designs we even got the search teams on
the back very nice very nice bouquet of
it number seven yes yes indeed you guys
black lives matter
love it love it in their respects and if
you guys didn't know we're also in the
middle plate for Elvis's GameSpot's
charity much appreciated much respect
sending the encouraging notes and now
we've got turtle up next let's see it
turtle oh yeah okay
parrot the truth merge with some gray
you know denim some distress denim
you've got the yellow loafers add the
complement of the colorings sandy
flooring in between I got the bamboos I
actually really love the van baby stuff
oh yes oh yeah definitely look like
working working out hard
oh man embodies the orange orange outfit
is probably my favorite so far very nice
very nice
all right who's next who's next
I want to reset the camera so here's a
little trick here you guys you open the
camera and then you take a picture right
away and it gets the HUD away oh he took
his outfit off because I think one of
his fashion outfits were all right let's
go Aaron let's see what you got
boom and he went in busted little which
goes very well with the shirt love the
color combination might I add yes much
much deserving of some applause let's
see it what's next are you glad to see
me I love it it's perfect
I love it I love it and the shoes
doesn't my shoes shoes we're having a
fashion show right now we are strutting
our stuff we've got some things for our
contestants and also some flourish
twisting so we are seeing them all I'm
look combos gotta give me the boom I
love it I love the all our moves office
also have some jokes in it it's really
funny if you can be creative with the
title they have to use outfits I really
like that and yeah pose all right what
ya got for us
Aaron Wow you managed to use the egg
shoes without them still got some space
cowboy Wow that is adorable for every
occasion I love it though that is
definitely space that way picture space
cowboy your admin you see this outfit it
makes a hundred percent
you so there's Elias top hat woohoo and
the nice shoes okay save the most
Colossians extravagant outfit for love
oh and a couple spins I love it
very nice I think I'll be alright stuff
here oh wait there's still one more oh
all right yes let's do this alright last
but certainly not least the fashionista
hair so let's go stuff let's see what
you got got the little Kermit on right
now it's cute alright Fred and she's got
the show perfect rude slag the Orange
Bowl I love and the kicks of course very
nice
she's moon walking down the runway yes
let the light shine on you it's
beautiful and she's striking love really
she is really a visa right now and I
love I'm living for it you got a channel
definitely
[Applause]
so classy I love it very nice
everyone's outfits has been so located
and sheets of fire and love this 80s
aerobics and shooter is awesome use the
rest of the clean wrestling
leotard and it fits perfectly I love an
eye for design because every time I see
the egg stuff anything yes if you look
at her the way she's standing next to
the backdrop everything right now
much approval very glamorous women I
know and I mean she was very excited
about the mermaid very she matches thank
you
I'm getting some awana vibes a little
bit
[Applause]
yeah strut your stuff girl strut your
stuff hey we are in Jeff Warner exactly
no autographs
Oh Ashley you section China you know
stay low profile
no autographs if you saw her title
unfair pass break it's actually
aggressive celebrity writing so funny
let's go make sense I love it
very cute that hat is adorable I realize
what's next what's next frequent flyer
all the danglars all the DAO merch I'm
personally trying to get that vieille
pilot jacket so cool I don't know how
many times I have to apply to get it one
day but look at all that exclusive rich
looking relaxed a little sleepy looks
like we've got one Oh
maximum alright that was it
[Applause]
my eyes turn on the light so thanks for
the final all right that fashion show
was amazing it's now time for the final
boss and this is our final chorus of the
day and this is going to end up in the
magical oasis it shouldn't take anyone
too long to get here since I kind of had
everyone practice transporting trees
earlier so we'll see we will see
[Music]
challenge alright bring it on it's gonna
run in circles until everyone gets out
here
[Music]
we can get everyone to do it I know we
can for maybe not
yes all right let's go guys
oops wrong one
[Music]
all right everyone make it house like
where's everybody else
there we go
come over here Brandon right here
Brandon
Brandon
all right to get through the maze Musa
all right we are gonna set this timer
for 15
I'm gonna run over here divide up my
ladder
I left some shovels because I kind of
felt like clear
their cubs were gonna break so let's see
here's the maze we've got going on you
guys everyone is going to have to dig up
the trees and make their way through Zoo
I believe some space for them to put the
trees elsewhere and once they make it
all the way through here and find out
which path is the correct path to go to
they can also find this little a mini
optional gold area that is set up here
see I have a ladder so I can get around
everywhere they also go a long way
oh I'm trapped over here - wait wait
wait I don't even know if I can get over
there because of my lights up which is
my still digging stuff up so I think got
time to run around and show you guys the
other side yeah they're keeping them in
their pocket so I hope they are able to
get through
I try to make sure everywhere oh yeah
how well they are doing that they need
to replant the trees elsewhere because
they are gonna run out of space all
right let's try to make it around to the
other side in time so you guys did get a
sneak peek of that side of the maze so
yeah this is sorts the end of the
minutes I don't think anyone's gone
a little bit of a closer look see if
anybody is ok ok they're making their
way through they are in the making their
way through all they found the girl
upside in there I love it there's random
your election I love that they
prioritize the secret gold nuggets that
I've hidden over there you see if I may
be narrow way through okay you guys
so now they're approaching the final
area so once they make their way through
here so I'm have to make it through here
but this this is what they've arrived
before all of these goodies so let's go
hang out over here and see who's gonna
make it so I did say you had to dig up
and move the trees to a different spot
for a specific reason because if they
get over here and our pockets are full
of trees they're gonna be wasting time
emptying their pockets and other people
are gonna snag all the gold so we'll see
let me see if I can use my camera to get
a better view
here oh yeah there they are
they're making their way through Oh
saying ah they all ran into that
direction they're so close they can
taste it fell in their fathers let it
fall in get all two dug it up the okay
smart see they have chuckles ed now it's
all for us they all made it through at
the same time which was also amazing let
me give a round of applause
oh my goodness
amazing well you guys we did it all of
our contestants not be one and this
one's so they're all walking away with a
high RL prize but everyone here is also
all the challenges and the fashion show
and how we've reached the end so thank
you guys so so much for tuning in this
was our second animal crossing
livestream by truth we pinch raise
awareness for good reasons help you stay
healthy and Stacey and I hope you guys
enjoyed what you saw today and enjoyed
hanging out with us because I definitely
had a lot of fun and you know we will do
stuff like this in the future again I
hope so if you're citizens make sure you
stay tuned and of course yeah stay safe
you guys eat some fruits and veggies and
have an awesome day we'll see you guys
next time thank you so much for tuning
in
take care
you